ce meurtre ce ce drame c'est
une horreur absolue et pour beaucoup de
nos compatriotes c'est c'est le drame de
trop
on peut pas on peut pas oublier vous
savez il y a il y a 5 ans le meurtre
l'assassinat par un
islamiste par daesh de des deux jeunes
filles
Laura et Morane à la gare de
Saint-Charles de Marseille on a limogé
le préfet parce qu'il avait pas pris de
qtf à l'égard du terrorisme de quitter
le territoire français là il y a une
obligation qui était le territoire
français et personne personne n'a rien
fait donc oui il y a un sujet personne
n'a rien fait Olivier Véran le
porte-parole du gouvernement rappelé que
les chiffres 10% environ de reconduites
effectivement 5% non non mais c'est une
bonne chose
2012 22% 2012 22% aujourd'hui 4 5 et
demi pour cent voilà la entre Nicolas
Sarkozy Emmanuel Macron non on est
aujourd'hui dans une situation
absolument
d'immigration non maîtrisée de l'axisme
de laxisme total c'est ce qui est
cette femme n'aurait plus dû être sur le
territoire français c'est la réalité et
les faits sont têtus vous aurez vos on
aura beau se cacher derrière tous les
appels à la dignité c'est ça aussi qui
choque qui choque notre patriote et
auquel il faut auquel il faut répondre
quand la famille dit pas de récupération
politique ne pas exploiter ce drame
affreux il y a un temps évidemment de de
respect du deuil de la famille c'est
évident mais c'est pour ça qu'on n'a pas
participé à quelques manifestations que
que ce soit mais on peut pas
ignorer
ignorer les causes de ce drame la
responsabilité des États depuis qu'il y
a des états depuis qu'il y a des pouvons
il y a un pouvoir dans tous les pays
c'est d'assurer la sécurité des plus
faibles cette ce drame c'est l'échec de
l'État collectivement je n'ai pas de
responsabilité sur des des quelques
personnes que ce soit c'est un échec il
faut pas dire le contraire il faut
attirer les conséquences merci